all right so we'll we're going to jump
right into the first question
and the first question is
why did god allow sin to enter into a
perfect world
why do you think adam sinned
adam sinned because he chose to sin
it was not an accident the bible is
clear eve was deceived adam was not
first timothy chapter 2
excuse me 13-14
now sin was allowed because the angels
had to understand how god functions go
to first peter chapter one let's read
verses 11 and 12. first peter chapter 1
verses 11 and 12.
this will tell us that the old testament
prophets while they were writing
did not fully understand what they were
writing
but they had to be told they were
writing for another generation so we'll
go to first peter
chapter 1 we read verses 11 and 12.
read very very carefully
do you have that
first peter 1
11 and 12.
searching what or what manner of time
the spirit of christ which was in them
did signify
when it testified beforehand the
suffering of christ and the glory that
shall fall now verse 12 unto whom it was
revealed that not unto themselves but
unto us they did minister to the things
which are now reported unto you by them
that have preached the gospel unto you
finish that verse
with the holy ghost come down from
heaven come on which things the angels
desire to look into which is the gospel
the angels do not understand
everything now compared to us
their minds are like encyclopedias don't
misunderstand me but they don't
understand everything
and so when lucifer fell
and the lord threw him out they did not
understand whether or not he was justly
treated
as a matter of fact eli white writes in
bible commentary volume 5 page 11 49
paragraph 10
it was only when they saw what lucy what
satan did to christ on the cross
that the last strings of sympathy with
satan were cut
imagine this for four
thousand years and more
there were angels in heaven who felt
lucifer had been unfairly treated
god had to allow sin that's the reason
why god allowed cain to live that the
universe may see what happens as sin
proceeds and progresses it's a painful
thing for god because he hates sin
hebrews 1 verse 9 thou hast love
righteousness and hated iniquity and the
things we hate we try to avoid god
cannot avoid sin
that's why when all the wicked are
finally destroyed
including satan but before he is
destroyed
every knee shall bow
and every tongue shall finally confess
that jesus christ is lord that has to
happen and for that to happen sin has to
be seen for what it really is so that
those of us who are saved having seen
what sin does
we will choose to live in a world where
sin will never return again
so god had to let it happen
and proceed yes and god always knows
best
that's why to please god you must
interact with him by faith
because he's god we're not and there's
so much it's like children and parents
children do not understand why the
father the mother said no
the parents understand the child doesn't
next question all right well let's jump
right into some controversy
let me say something before we get into
the controversy
the question also why did adam sin
adam put someone ahead of god
genesis 3 verse 17 and unto adam he said
because thou has heartened unto the
voice of thy wife
and has eaten of the tree of which i
commanded thee saying thou shalt not eat
of it cursed is the ground for thy sake
god said you listen to someone else
instead of me
i hit a harp on this but let me harp
when you observe sunday
you're listening to someone else instead
of god
and i'll leave it at that yes master all
right what is your opinion
on the vaccine
i have no opinion
i'll tell you what the church's official
position is
you must make an individual choice
based on praying to god for guidance
following the health laws the counselors
of ellen white and then making your
individual decision
that's the position of the church and i
am no position to go against the church
because i see nothing sinful about that
council
make your individual decision remember
psalm 32 verse 8 i will instruct thee
and teach thee in the way which thou
shalt go psalm 25 verse 4 show me thy
ways o lord teach me thy paths james 1
verse 5 if any of you lack wisdom let
him ask of god that given to all men
liberally jeremiah 33 verse 3 call unto
me and i will answer thee and show the
great and mighty things which thou
knowest ask god should i take the
vaccine
he will convict you one way or the other
because your body belongs to him
amen
all right
what do you think is the reason we are
losing members our members and and what
is your solution
john 12 well the bible has a solution i
don't have one
john 12
32 and i
if i be lifted up from the earth will
draw all men unto me the first
application of that verse is crucifixion
he was lifted up on the cross it also
means lift him up when you preach lift
up truth truth will draw people to
christ in the great controversy page 509
paragraph one ella white writes
conformity to worldly custom
never convert converts the church to the
world it never converts the world to
christ let me say that again conformity
to worldly custom
converts the church to the world
it never converts the world to christ
when you mingle the things of god with
the secular things you weaken the power
of the message and people drift
are you following me
god called the israelites to be
different
and they said to samuel in 1st samuel
chapter 8 make us a king to judge us
like the other nations
when you're called to be different
and you act as though you want to be
like everybody else it is an insult to
god you are desiring a path contrary to
the one for which god brought you into
existence to be different and so we lose
members because we drift from the truth
i was conducting an evangelistic series
in a certain church in canada
and i told them we'll meet every night
for three weeks and they said every
night so this little
opposition to that so the pastor said
come and talk to the members so i flew
to the city where it was
and sat down and met with him
and uh they gave me all kinds of reasons
why they can't come every night i said
to one when can you come tuesday night
well you come on tuesday night
when can you come wednesday when you
come on wednesday
but i can't shut down the meeting
because you cannot come on the thursday
so we have the meeting and the past of
that meeting told me
to in the third week
of all the meetings they have had in the
past
the average attendance at night was
about 30 people
we averaged 160 people
because all i did
was to do what give them thus saith the
lord
that's no joke there's god listening to
me
i was called to do an evangelistic
series in minneapolis
and one night the executive secretary or
ministerial director of the conference
came
and he saw the people
so he asked the local pastor
how do you get 200 people in a church on
a tuesday night
and the pastor said
listen to me
they're all kind of gimmicks churches
use to so-called hold people
holding someone in a church building is
not holding the person in christ
there are two different things
you can hold someone in the building
is the person in christ only this this
keeps a person in christ
in all my travels i've observed
this attracts old and young
and i get texo all the time young people
telling me they want to walk with god
god is my witness young people all the
time pastor have sinned i want to get
close to god and i give them this
this
all right next question
in one of your sermons you say that the
devil this is the devil's world
could you explain that a little bit yes
let's pray again father as i continue
answering questions for your beloved
people continue to grant wisdom to the
pastor and me in jesus name i pray amen
the temptations of christ are found in
two places matthew 4 and luke 4.
in matthew 4 is eat turn stones to bread
jump off the building worship me in luke
it is turn stones to bread worship me
jump off the building now in luke's
version luke chapter 4 6 and the devil
said unto him all this power will i give
thee and the glory of them
for that is delivered unto me
and to whomsoever i will i give it satan
is saying all this was given to me when
when adam sinned
are you with me now when jesus died he
bought it back
but it's not yet in his control are you
with me
christ legally bought the world back the
reason why satan went up to heaven in
job 1
for six now there was a day when the
sons of god came to present themselves
before the lord and satan came also
among them
he came to represent the earth and the
lord said unto sin whence came us thou
then satan answered the lord and said
from going to and fro in the earth and
from walking up and down in it
symbolizing that's mine
because when god promised canaan to mock
abraham he told him in genesis 13 verse
16 arise
walk through the land in the length of
it and in the breath of it so god told
abraham to do exactly what satan said he
was doing
expressing possession and so in a
certain sense this is the devil's world
in john chapter 14 verse 30 jesus said
the prince of this world cometh the word
prince the greek word arkhan means a
ruler and has nothing in me second
corinthians 4 4 paul says the god of
this world have blinded the minds and so
yes in a practical sense the devil this
is the devil's world but christ has
bought it back legally but the devil is
still squatting
along with his people and christ is
coming to remove the squatters do not be
among them get to christ when you're
with christ you are legally inhabiting
the world you're not squatting
all right let's let's just have a
follow-up to that yes if you don't mind
okay oh follow up okay
uh pastor so
in a sense god made an exception
in allowing satan into that meeting
because we know that sin cannot exist in
the presence of a holy ghost
that was the question that the pastors
are looting no no satan did not stand in
the full presence of god remember
that uh jesus
is the lamb slain from the foundation of
the world are you following me the
administrator of the universe is the
creator that's christ the same way the
blood of christ was effective from the
foundation of the world
so was his humanity
so anyone coming you see you can't have
bloodshed without humanity
i don't want to be deep or tough think
abraham was saved by the blood of christ
before it was shed are you with me noah
by the blood of christ well it means the
humanity of christ had to be effective
for his blood to be effective because
the spirit can't bleed
are you with me
and so
because of christ he could come
but he couldn't come into the full
presence of the father
through christ he could come up to
heaven
and we don't know exactly where in
heaven he was you see all right
thank you
okay
all right
are people who don't people the people
who don't keep the sabbath but they make
it to heaven people who disobey god will
be lost
are you with me
people who willfully deliberately
fragrantly directly high-handedly
disobey god will be lost because if god
saves them sin will start all over again
so when the person says well those who
don't keep the sabbath to be lost martin
luther didn't keep the sabbath
eloy said he'd be in the kingdom
william miller didn't keep the sabbath
he was not convicted he'll be in the
kingdom during the dark ages there were
thousands and millions who knew nothing
about the sabbath because it was an age
of darkness but god knew the heart of
those people they'd be saved but when in
1844 october 22 the temple was opened
then the light of the law flashed out
all over the world so that excuse is
gone
are you with me blessed are they that do
his commandments that they may have
right this is not salvation by works
this is expressing your love through
obedience
all right
so
i guess this kind of connects with the
question is can you explain imputed
right righteousness imputed
righteousness is what god does for us
in part of the righteousness imperialize
is what he does in us
uh when you come to christ
a sinner i'm sorry forgive me
immediately christ's righteousness
covers you
and his righteousness stands in your
place
now listen to what you said stands in
your place
let me put it this way
you're in school university of
missouri city
and you get
f
e
g plus h minus those are your grades are
you with me
now you come to christ
and you submit to him
read out christ's score for me a plus a
plus a plus a plus a plus plus plus
those are the grades christ has in
righteousness he puts that to your name
when you come to him
let me tell you why that's necessary
a perfect life the bible says the law of
the lord is perfect
a perfect law requires a perfect life
you said amen but did you get what i'm
saying
a perfect law cannot tolerate an
imperfect life
if it tolerated it it ceases to be a
perfect law a perfect lord demands a
perfect life
which means you have to be perfect in
the past
in the present
and you must be perfect in the future
are you with me the only person who's
lived that life is christ
so when you come to christ
and you truly surrender you convicted by
his love as expressed on calvary you
want to do everything that pleases him
but the spirit is willing but the flesh
is me you understand
christ accepts you and covers you with
his righteousness and so eloise rights
in step to christ paid 62 paragraphs to
if you give yourself to him
and accept him as your savior then
sinful as your life may have been
for his sake you counted righteous
christ's character is put in place of
your character and you are accepted by
god just as if you had never sinned
okay okay give me one minute
this is so astounding people don't
believe it
they don't believe it the gospel is the
most astonishing that's why angels
cannot understand it
that the very listen to ii corinthians 5
21 for he god the father hath made him
christ to be sin for us
whom you know sin that's christ and you
know sin that we might be made the
righteousness of god in him
we must be made righteous
because we cannot make ourselves
righteous
god was god made jesus to be sin because
jesus never made himself sin by sinning
and so imputed righteousness is what is
given to us
when we come to christ the important
righteousness is that power that takes
us from day to day
one is our title to heaven that's
imputed the other is our fitness for
heaven for instance let's say my little
brother is 12 and he's next in line to
be king of some country in europe
somewhere but he's only 12.
now he has to wait till he's 18. he has
the title but he does not have the
fitness are you with me let me say it
again he has the title but he doesn't
have the fitness so when you come to
christ i'm sorry like that publican in
luke 18. he left
with the right
the title he now had to develop the
fitness of christ had to work out the
fitness in him and so imputed as a title
imparted provides the fitness
for
a place in god's kingdom yes my brother
one second hold on a second please
mike
because the people we wanted people
online to hear
so what you just explained
then the dilemma in the church now
is what we hear people will be sinning
until jesus come no
no no no no we see
look at look at daniel daniel loved god
so much
when he had a choice between sin
and death finish my words
he chose death
we have to come to that point look at
the three hebrew boys who refused to bow
they had a choice between bow and live
and refuse to bow and die they chose
death not knowing they be saved
paul went to jerusalem acts 20 saying i
know what's waiting for me but i don't
count my life pressures when you see
hebrews 2 14 verse 15
for as much then as the children are
partakers of flesh and blood he also
himself likewise took part of the same
that through death he might destroy him
that had the power of death that is the
devil and delivered them who through
fear of death
were all the lifetime subject the
bondage genuine surrender to christ
brings you to the place where you prefer
to die
then knowingly sin against god no we
will come to the place where we will not
sin
believe this we continue saying to jesus
listen to me
god put adam out for one sin
he can't let you in with one
is jesus actually god yes
that's so heavy let me pray again father
i lord as i deal with this you talk to
me
just take me out of the way and just
talk to me let me be possessed by your
spirit
in jesus name i pray
amen
go to first timothy chapter three
first timothy chapter three
i recognize that young professor right
there
do you have first timothy chapter three
do you have verse 16
if you have the king james version read
it with me carefully are we ready
let's read and
without controversy great is the mystery
of godliness come on god was manifest in
the flesh stop
now stop stop stop thank you for being
eager to read god bless you
god was come on
manifest in the flesh that's the great
mystery
great mystery but we must understand
sufficient because as we understand it
it changes us god was manifest in the
flesh now let's add to that go to
matthew 1.
matthew 1
is aaron back there
could you take that picture off
please
you can put a q a one yeah put some like
that take off
that
ball-headed vegetarian all right
did i say matthew chapter 1
all right
let's read verse 21 are you there
read with me and she shall bring forth a
son come on and thou shall call his name
jesus why for he shall save his people
from their sin from how many sins all
they say
not some all now
what is his work in verse 21
he saves them
from their sin
but who is he go to verse 23
who is this person that saves them from
their sins read for me
behold a virgin shall be with child come
on and shall bring forth a son come on
and they shall call his name emmanuel
which being interpreted is god with us
now what is the work he does in verse 21
who is he in verse 23 god
only god
can save you
it's a it's a
it's an era i see in the church
for those of us who believe some
advances believe jesus is not equal with
the father
only god
can save you go to romans chapter 1.
6 41.
do you have romans 1 16
you don't have it yet is in the new
testament
you have it now
okay read with me what does this say for
i am not ashamed of the gospel of christ
nice and loud for it is the power of the
angel gabriel unto salvation
the power of god
only the power of god
can save you
yes christ is god
was christ worshipped when he was on
this earth because he was god and man at
the same time i never said christ is the
father but christ is fully god go to
hebrews 1.
and i'm glad this question was asked
you'd be amazed what people believe in
the adventist church
which is not among the official
doctrines by the way do you have hebrews
this is the father speaking to the son
one of my favorite chapters
here's what the father says in verse 8.
and what does that read that for me
thy throne
but of the son he saith thy throne o god
is forever and ever stop what does the
father call him oh god
oh god
a scepter of righteousness is the
scepter of thy kingdom what is the
father saying jesus has a kingdom
when you read read microscopically thank
you very much
verse 9
thou hast love righteousness and hated
iniquity skipped the verse 10 and thou
lord in the beginning
has laid the foundation of the earth and
the heavens at the work of thy hand stop
the father says
who created heaven and earth
come on who the son
read verse 11. they shall perish
but thou remain is stop
what's that what does that tell you
about jesus and creation
they shall perish
creation will do what
pass away
but thou
what does that mean
christ is eternal
the father is
proclaiming the eternal nature of jesus
they shall perish but they'll reach
their remains and they all shall wax all
this as the death of garment
huh
but thou are the same and thy years
shall not fail
that's eternal christ is an eternal
being
now since the father identified christ
as god
he called him lord in verse 8.
lord god in verse 8 lord in verse 10.
let's go to psalms 90. we know who the
creator is let's go to psalm 19.
somebody say amen for the bible
you have psalm 90
read from verse 1
lord thou has been our dwelling place in
all generations before the mountains
were brought for stop who brought the
mountains forth
jesus before the mountains were brought
forth or ever thou has formed the earth
and the world even from everlasting to
everlasting finishing thou art god
jesus is as divine as the father
and the holy spirit is as divine as the
father
now they have different
functions
are you with me
in divinity they're like this
in function they're like that
are you with me
we have father son holy spirit equally
divine each one but in function we have
father we have son we have holy spirit
go to john 13 16. i'm taking a little
while this is important pastor
now we have from six until the sun sets
i didn't say i'll take all that time i
just said we have it from six until the
sun says
okay where did i send you john what
chapter 13 what first 16. now most of
the reading is coming from the left
let me hear someone from the right read
as well i just keep hearing from the
left
but let's all read together are you with
me read with me now verily verily i say
unto you the servant is not greater than
his lord come on neither he that is sent
greater than him that sent him now we
have two people in that verse name them
the servant
and the lord who's greater
come on be confident even if you're
wrong who's greater the lord
and the lord is the one who does what
he sends
now listen to john 17 3.
no you don't have to go there you know
it and this is life eternal that they
might know thee the only true god and
jesus christ whom thou has sent referee
john 5 john 17 whom the sent have sent
have sent have sent now it means with
respect to authority who is higher the
one who sends
go to john 15.
somebody said okay
john 15.
read verse 20. are you there
what does that say read for me remember
the word that i said unto you the
servant is not greater than his lord
[Music]
if they have persecuted him
they will do what
yes if they did it to me they won't do
it to you
the servant is not greater that the one
who sends is greater than the one who
sent him now go to john 14.
let's read verse 28
are you there read for me i said what
does it say you have heard how i said
unto you i go to my way and come again
unto you if he loved me you will rejoice
because i said what i go unto the father
for my father is greater than i now in
what sense is the father greater in the
sense of authority and responsibility
not in the sense of divinity
the father
the son and holy spirit are fully divine
and white calls them the three great
powers of heaven who are working for our
salvation
but with authority let me show you again
the authority go to john 14.
read verse 26.
but the comforter come on
which is the holy ghost whom the father
shall send in my name stop
the comforter
the father will send him in my name
the name is the authority of jesus
now go to john 15.
read verse 26
oh hold on hold on let's read together
are we ready let's wait what does it say
but when the comforter is come whom i
will send unto you from the father even
the spirit of truth which proceeded from
the father he shall
now jesus says i will send him in verse
26 of chapter 15. jesus said the father
will send him verse 26 john 14 in other
words the father and the son can send
the spirit
the spirit doesn't send them anywhere
now when christ was on earth in his
humanity the spirit directed him luke 4
18 the spirit of the lord is upon me
because he hath anointed me to preach
yes but as god
he said that what happened at pentecost
jesus sent the spirit
to give him thomas
jesus is fully god
and if you don't believe that you may
have a nice religious life
but you cannot be saved by someone less
than god
i say again jesus christ let me give you
one more verse go to isaiah 9.
isaiah 9.
are you there
who can guess what verse i want you to
read
who can guess the verse
someone who loves jesus who can guess
the verse
six
six all right are you are there six let
me pray again father continue to be with
us all as we listen to your word and try
to understand under the guidance of your
spirit in jesus name i pray amen read
with me for unto us a child is given
unto us a child is born unto us a son is
given and the government shall be on his
shoulder and his name shall be called
wonderful come on counselor come on
the mighty god stop the mighty god keep
reading the everlasting father the
prince of peace a better translation of
everlasting father is the father of
eternity
you see eternity flows from jesus
that's a concept we can't understand
because eternity has no end but it come
jesus is the source
of eternity
so he's the father the everlasting
father mean the father of
everlastingness and he's called the
mighty god we need to understand this
stupendous fact
that the person in that manger with arms
and legs wriggling in the air helpless
was the one who said let there be light
and he took that step
to save us
no one less than christ
could have come to die
because he had to give up the life that
is naturally his
if the angel gabriel had come to die he
would have been giving up a life that's
not his
because he received life from the
creator are you following me the life
had to be the life that naturally
belongs to the victim dying on that
cross only christ can fulfill that
no angel could but the angels wanted to
come and die
no you can't die for sin the life is not
yours
i can die because the life is mine and
so i give it up
and i take it back up
go to john i keep saying one more verse
go to john 10.
i want you to leave here understanding
jesus christ is fully god
don't put your salvation in peril by
believing he's less than god john 10
verse 3 from verse 16
and you found it let me know
read with me and other sheep i have
which are not of this fold them also i
must bring and they will hear my voice
and there shall be one fold and one
shepherd keep reading therefore doth my
father love me because i laid on my life
that i might take it again verse 18
no man taketh it from me stop
jesus wasn't killed
jesus gave up his life
now you're saying yes because you're
nice
but do you understand what i'm saying
jesus gave up his life
if he had been killed it would have been
an unwilling sacrifice are you with me
he willingly gave up his life so he says
in verse 18 no man taketh it from me but
i laid down of myself now finish the
verse i have power to lay down
now stop wait wait a minute no dead
person can raise himself
jesus raised himself now the bible says
the father raised him the father the
bible says that because the father told
him when to get up
but jesus said destroy this temple and
in three days i will rise
if the father had raised him jesus would
need an assistant no christ needs no
assistance to save us
so hebrews 1 verse 3 when he had by
himself purged our sins and to purge the
sins required the death
and the resurrection
are you with me to purge sins requires
death and resurrection go back to the
sanctuary the sinner brought the lamb
the lamb was slain that's the death of
christ the priest is the living christ
and he goes into the temple to apply the
blood
you must have death
and resurrection to have sins taken care
of
jesus christ
is fully god somebody say amen for jesus
all right next question all right so we
established the fact that jesus christ
is fully god
let's now deal with the holy spirit yes
is the holy spirit a separate being
is he the spirit of the father or spirit
of jesus
some argue that the trinity is a
catholic teaching
and that the founders of the seventh
adventist church did not believe in the
trinity let me
listen to me carefully
when we hear the word heathen
and pagan and catholic we start to panic
are you with me
now
do pagans eat breakfast
do we eat breakfast
is that pagan behavior
are you following me
is that do do pagans wear clothes do we
wear clothes is that pagan behavior no
now the catholics believe in the trinity
it doesn't make it wrong because they
believe in the trinity they believe that
christ is fully god
that's not a catholic doctrine that's a
biblical doctrine not everything
catholics believe is wrong but where
they're wrong they are catastrophically
wrong are you following me
no you're not listening to me
so they believe some things that are
biblical
and if you believe the bible you believe
the same thing the doctrine of the
trinity is biblical not catholic now
let's go to matthew 3.
matthew 3
you have brother matthew
chapter 3
you read from verse 16.
what happened that versus exactly what
happened this morning at a beta
all right read with me and jesus when he
was baptized went up straight away out
of the water and lord the heavens were
opened unto him and he saw the spirit of
god descending like a dove and lighting
upon him and law a voice from heaven
saying this is my beloved son in whom i
am well please now let's look at it
microscopically
and i asked god to continue to be with
this session please in the name of jesus
where
was jesus
in the world he was coming out
in what direction was the dove traveling
so we have two different beings
where does the dove sit on the shoulder
some on the shoulder jesus
the voice we hear where did they come
from
where above
so we have
someone coming down now the spirit can
take any form remember in acts 2 the
cloven tongues like us a fire that's
divine power you see we don't understand
that
the spirit came down
sat on christ who was coming out of the
water
and a voice said this is my beloved son
in whom i am well please we have father
we have son
we have holy ghost go to matthew 28.
the bible is simple if we're honest
it's very simple when you're honest
i'm not trying to defend tradition
matthew 28 reading from verse 18 read
with me and jesus came and spake unto
them saying all power is given unto me
in heaven and in earth go on go ye
therefore and teach all nations
baptizing them in the name of the father
and of the son and of the holy
in the name of the father the name of
the son name of the holy ghost name
represents character power and authority
because romans 8 9 tells us if any man
hath not the spirit of christ
he is none of his we must be baptized in
the name of the father the son and the
holy ghost now
let's go to john 3 verse 8.
is the holy ghost a separate person is
he divine
john 3 verse 8 it's 3 minutes to 7.
do you have john 3 verse 8
read with me the wind bloweth where it
listeth and now here is the sound
thereof but can't not tell whence it
cometh or whether it goeth so is
everyone that is born of the spirit now
what do you understand by born of the
spirit what's that
born again the new birth conversion or
justification by faith
only god can do that
and jesus says the spirit is the force
that carries out that carries it out
only god can deliver you from sin
let's go to acts 13.
acts 13 we read from verse 1.
there are some names you need to
pronounce carefully in that chapter but
go undergo the discipline of pronouncing
these names because we don't read the
bible because the names are different
undergo the discipline
of trying to pronounce don't quit and
give up your child of god
christ fell he got up he fell he got up
he walked up the cavalry kept falling he
kept getting up they finally helped him
but he made it because he saw you so
never quit too easily quit sin quickly
but not other things all right first one
acts 13 what does that say
now there were in the church that was at
antioch certain
prophets and
as
uh-huh
lucius
and saul who had been brought up with my
name
okay
let me get home read it again and we'll
be much better okay now verse 2 says
what as they
minister and lord and fastid come on the
holy ghost said stop
speech is one of the highest expressions
of intelligence
that's why animals don't speak although
they're intelligent
the holy ghost
said what did he say keep reading
separate me
barnabas and saul for the work where
unto i have
now look at verse one again how many
people were there read the names again
barnabas
simeon
lucius
manian
and saul
now five
the holy ghost said i want how many
two
he deliberately selected the two he
wanted
that's the power of
discrimination
to the work we're unto finish verse two
i have called them
can electricity make a call to you to go
preach for christ
can energy do that the holy spirit is an
individual intelligent being we don't
understand
him by the way for those of us who are
tempted to think the holy ghost is less
than anybody else let me issue a
biblical warning for you
go to matthew 12.
matthew 12.
you have matthew 12.
let's read verse 31
of matthew 12.
are you there what does that say
wherefore i say unto you all manner of
sin and blasphemy shall be forgiven the
men
but the blasphemy against the
shall not be forgiven
read verse 32 and whoso
speaketh a word against the son of
it shall be
but whoso speaketh a word against the
it shall not be forgiven him neither in
this world come on neither in the world
be careful what you say about the holy
spirit
you talk about jesus forgiveness is
possible
you run your tongue in your mouth
against the holy spirit
and that's jesus speaking
be very careful how you talk about the
spirit of god
now we read in john 3 8 the spirit saves
he's the one who carries out the new
birth go to isaiah 45
isaiah 45
read for me verse 22.
are you there
read for me what does this say look unto
me and be saved all the ends of the
earth come on for i am
and there is
what does that mean by i am god there is
none else
yes okay what else read the whole verse
look unto me and be
safe stop that's the activity be look
and be saved now he says for i am god
there's none else what does he mean by
that
i am the only one who can save you but
we read in john 3 8
the new birth is brought about by the
spirit and jesus himself said that then
the spirit must be fully god because
only god
can save you
all right
next question
a lot of seven adventists believe that
wearing jewelry example earrings chains
are not a sin
and that they can wear them
some also believe that body tattoos are
not sin
what does god say
all right
i knew trouble was coming soon
let's pray
father
give us a heart to receive biblical
truth
and not social customs
in jesus name i pray amen
go to genesis 3.
we read verse
six and verse seven
well let's read from one to seven read
the bible
genesis three one to seven we're talking
about ornaments and decorations on the
outside all that stuff we call jewelry
which is such a big business
do you have it
now the serpent was more subtle than any
beast of the field which the lord god
had made
and he said unto the woman yea hath god
said he shall not eat of every tree of
the garden
and a woman said unto the serpent we may
eat of the fruit of the trees of the
garden
but of the fruit of the tree which is in
the midst of the garden god has said he
shall not eat of it neither shall he
touch it lest ye die
and the serpent said unto the woman ye
shall not surely die for god doth know
that in the day ye eat thereof then your
eyes shall be opened and ye shall be as
gods knowing good and evil verse six and
when the woman saw that the tree was
good for food which it was not by the
way and that was pleasant to the eyes
and a tree to be desired to make one
wise she took of the fruit thereof and
did eat and gave also unto her husband
with her and he did it now verse 8 and
the eyes of them both were up verse 7
and they knew that they were naked and
they sowed fig leaves together and made
themselves aprons what was made in verse
what
what was made
be specific
aprons of
leaves let's go to verse 21
read for me
unto adam also and to his wife did the
lord god make coats of skins and clothe
them okay i want to draw some of your
attention
what was made on the first day
too slow too slow too slow light second
day
for a moment third day
is this an adventist church
fourth day
sun moon and stars fifth day
birds and fish sixth day land animals
and human beings question for you what
did adam and eve make
in that week of creation
nothing
nothing all the making the creating was
done by god
go back to genesis 3 7.
we're looking at a principle
a negative principle
read verse 7 again
and the eyes of them both were open
and they knew that they were naked stop
read verse 25 of chapter 2
and they were both naked the man and his
wife and were not ashamed are you with
me but that was before
sin
after sin
they're ashamed
so what are they trying to deal with
the embarrassment the shame the guilt
that's what they're trying to handle
how do they handle it
they made airprints of leaves now that's
the first thing the bible records a
human being ever made on the earth
something to cover where
the outside
are you not listening to me
something to beautify
the outside
something to help me feel a little
better about myself
are you with me
with this principle in mind
now
let's go to zechariah 3.
zechariah 3.
are you there
not yet
come on come on find zechariah find
malachi then work your way back malachi
okay you got it now
you're sure
i said zechariah
you have zechariah
chapter 3
what's the first word in there
and he showed me joshua the high priest
come on standing before the angel of the
lord and satan standing at his right
hand to resist him
keep reading and he
unto satan the lord rebuked thee o satan
even the lord that have chosen jerusalem
rebuke thee is not this a brand plucked
out of the fire verse three now joshua
was clothed with filthy garments stop
describe the leaves
filthy garments
because god had to remove them are you
following me 50 garments now joshua's
clothed in filthy garments and stood
before the angel keep reading and he
answered and speaking to those that
stood before him saying what take away
the filthy garments from him and to him
he said behold i have caused that
iniquity to pass from thee and i will
clothe thee with change of raymond now
in joshua we have a symbol of how god
functions he removes that man-made stuff
and replaces it with the symbol of the
righteousness of his son are you with me
now let's go back to genesis
genesis 3 21 keep the information from
zechariah 3 verse 1 to 4. let's go to
genesis 3 verse 21 unto adam also
and to his wife did the lord god make
coats of skins and clothe them before he
put the skins on what did he have to
remove those aprons of leaves man-made
for the purpose of feeling better
reducing a sense of guilt and shame
now to see how worthless the aprons were
let's go to verse 8 of genesis 3
and they heard the voice of the lord god
walking in the garden in the cool of the
day and adam and his wife hid themselves
from the presence of the lord god
amongst the trees of the garden now why
are they hiding if they're already
covered
because there's no human covering that
can improve your appearance in the sight
of god are you following me no you're
not following me
verse 21 coats of skin the blood of
christ
is what needs to cover us now having
said all of that
let us go to
exodus exodus no genesis 35
it's 10 after seven when does the sun
eat what
temperance and all things temperance
temperance okay
we're going to genesis 35
we're even verse one
let me pray father as we continue
please lord teach us we want to know
because salvation is knowledge
teach us their god in the name of jesus
christ i pray amen now let me set this
up for you in chapter 34 simeon and levi
kill all the men in the city
because the prince of that city had
raped their sister jacob had 13 children
12 boys and one girl
you know that girl can be protected
when she was raped simeon and levi went
to the city and said to the prince look
you defiled our sister
you have to marry her
the prince said yeah i'll marry you
but the boy said you can't marry her
because you're uncircumcised
the prince said we'll get circumcised so
simon levi the servants came and
circumcised all the men
waited three days for them to be
properly immobile are you following me
then came with the swords
and killed
all the men
brought the women into captivity and the
children all the possessions of the city
and in the field and took it all away
and when this terrible thing happened
jacob said the surrounding tribes will
kill me because i'm just a small group
now god is going to get them out of this
are you following me he's getting them
out of this crisis that's what we're
about to read verse 1 genesis 35 and god
said unto jacob arise
go up bethel and dwell there and make
there an altar unto god that appeared
unto thee when thou fled us from the
face of esau thy brother remember jacob
running from esau okay
verse two
then jacob said unto his household and
to all that with him
put away the strange gods that are among
you and be clean and change your
garments this is a spiritual change
you've offended god
changes have to be made put away of
strange gods
be clean change your garments now verse
three what does that say
and let us arise and go up to bethel and
i will make the an altar unto god that
what answered me in the day of my
distress and which was with me in the
way which i went
now
jacob said in first two put over the
strange gods be clean change a garment
verse four read with me now
and they gave unto jacob all the strange
gods which were in their hands and all
the earrings which were in their ears
and jacob hid them under the oak which
was by shechem now
all the jewelry
jacob took
and buried it
go to matthew 25
25 we'll read from verse 14.
are you with me
you have matthew 25
verse 14
okay you say yes but you're still
turning pages all right okay
okay
are we there now can i rely on that yes
okay read with me for the kingdom of is
as a man traveling into a far country
who called his own servants and
delivered unto them his goods next verse
and until one he gave five talents to
another two and to another one to every
man according to several abilities and
away took his journey now next verse 16
i think it is now he that had received
the five talents went and traded with
the same and made them other five
talents likewise he that had received
two he also gained other two read verse
went and digged in the earth and hid his
lord's money what did jacob do with the
jewelry
in the earth what does this man do to
tell him
signifying what
how did the fellow with five get ten
what did he do
yes he traded he used it are you with me
are you following he used it got went
from five to ten what about the fellow
who went from two to four he used it
he put it to use
the fella with one what did he do
he buried it meaning what
he didn't use it
what did jacob do with that jewelry
he buried it it was not to be
used
go to exodus 33
exodus 33
we have another crisis the israelites
are full of crises we have another
crisis
these people have just worshipped the
golden calf
and god was this close to wiping them
out
moses sent the levites with their swords
three thousand were killed in that day
now god wants them to do something to
show repentance and a change of mind and
heart verse 1
exodus 33 let me know when you're there
read with me and the lord said unto
moses depart and go up hence thou and
the people which thou has brought up out
of the land of egypt unto the land which
i swear unto abraham to isaac and to
jacob saying unto thy seed will i give
it
keep reading and i will send my angel
before thee and i will drive out the
canaanite the amorite and the hittite
and the perisite the hi-vite and the
jebusite now verse three unto a lamb
flowing with milk and honey reading for
i will not go up in the midst of thee
for ye are uh that are the stiff naked
people lest i consume you in the way god
is saying i am so mad
i don't want to travel with you
in your condition because i'll just
destroy you
is god love
can god get mad
is his madness just yes
verse 4 and when the people heard these
evil tithings come on they mourned and
no man did put on him he they did refuse
to put all jewelry they had
verse 5
for the lord that said unto moses say
unto the children of israel ye are a
stiff-naked people i will come up in the
midst of thee in a moment and consume
thee therefore now put off thy ornaments
from there that i may know
what to do
unto thee
verse 6
and the children of israel strip
themselves of the ornaments by the mount
of now let me tell you the hebrew
rendering strip themselves by the mount
means from the mount or meaning from
that point on
they left them off
from mount horeb
they left them off subsequent travels
we have two spiritual crises and god
says you need to straighten yourself out
on each occasion get rid of all that
stuff
now
go to ezekiel 28.
let's read from verse 13. this is a
description of lucifer
before he fell are you with me
i'm not convinced you are but okay
ezekiel 28
reading from verse 13 are you there okay
some are you still looking for ezekiel
all right i give you 10 seconds to find
ezekiel it's 7 18.
you have ezekiel 28 18 13 read with me
thou has been in eden the garden of god
every precious stone was thy covering
come on the sardius the topaz the
diamond what else the barrel onyx the
jasper what else the sapphire the
emerald the carbuncle and gold keep
reading the workmanship of thy
tabernacle of thy pies was prepared in
thee in the day that that was created
who is that lucifer he was covered with
precious stones
let's find out what his problem was go
to verse 17 and read it for me
come on
thine heart was lifted up in the y
because of thy beauty come on that has
corrupted thy wisdom by reason of thy
brightness stop
when lucifer realized how pretty he was
thine heart was lifted up in thee
because of thy beauty you know you went
in high school the most stuck-up person
was the girl who thought she was the
prettiest
his outward appearance
led to his
i'm not saying there's only reason but
it contributed
now
when god made lucifer he was covered
with all that stuff
when god made adam
was this sin in the world in the
universe
when god made adam was the sin in the
universe yes
who would sin for lucifer are you with
me so did god know the catastrophe he
had with this pretty angel
how did he make adam give me one word
starts with n
naked
what did he have on him nothing
what did eve have on her nothing
now
does god want us to breathe
what did he give us we're two holes are
you with me
ah you're not listening
does he want us to listen
what did he give us
with holes
if he wanted us to wear earrings
you got to put another hole right here
and one right here
uh you don't like me anymore
are you listening to me
yeah
he made adam and eve with nothing on
them
a baby comes out of the womb and two
days later you pound the hole in the air
and you pound them and you drive a
screwdriver through something and you
cuff some with a saw to hide metal
let me tell you some of jewelry in
ancient times
people wore them to identify with their
idols
some jewelry formed were called amulets
and amulet was devised to protect you
from evil spirits
some jewelry had markings on them that
represented the idols
and as the idols were decorated people
decorate themselves so they look like
come on they're idols
go to leviticus 19.
leviticus 19.
i forgot to welcome those listening
online
wherever you are god bless you
and may the truth of his word reach you
unopposed
what book did i say leviticus what
chapter 19 read verse 28 microscopically
are you there and keep in mind the key
word that describes or summarizes
leviticus is
holiness
read verse 28 now
ye shall make no cuttings in your flesh
for the dead
or print
marks upon you
i am now
don't cut yourself
don't print marks on you
that's what people did to identify with
the dead and their ancestors whom they
worshipped are you following me
remember the prophets of baal
on mount carmel
with elijah when baal wouldn't answer
what does this have to do cut them all
don't do that
now
when god says don't cut yourself what
does he mean don't cut yourself don't
tell god it's a little cut
pastor they don't like what i'm saying
don't tell god but it's just a little
cut
because adam could have said it's just a
grape
that's all i consumed
why are you putting me out god said
don't do it
now to have earrings in your ear do you
have to pierce it
or some do you up here is that a cut
why are you hesitating as dory why
stammer is that a cut yes
don't make me mad
the verse says don't print any marks on
your body
are your toes a part of your body
come on tell me you don't sound sure huh
why are they red
that's a mark
now someone is saying this guy is
extreme
i'm not extreme
you either
for god
or you're not now let me say this some
people are convicted at different times
different time i was preaching somewhere
and i made a call to give up all that
jewelry people came and put rings and on
the table
and i told the head elder the pastor
sell it and give the money to the doctor
society
they took it off and put it there
go to first timothy chapter two
i know someone watching me wants to kill
me but
the pastor is here to protect me he
won't let me get killed you want to kill
me i know that
i feel that heat coming from you
first timothy chapter 2 let's read from
verse 9.
i'll miss you when i'm gone
i really will
god bless you all the days of your life
god bless you god bless you i mean it
first peter first timothy chapter 2 do
you have that
let me pray father as we continue
teach us god we forget quickly teach us
and soften that stony heart that does
not like what is being said in jesus
name i pray amen
first timothy 2 verse 9 says what
in like manner also that women adorn
themselves with modest power in modest
apparel with shame-facedness and
sobriety let me tell you something
modesty is almost extinct
when i was a boy you know what a modest
person looks like
modesty today is almost extinct
people in the church no longer
understand what modesty is i was coming
through johannesburg south africa and uh
oh
and i saw a lady dressed
and the moment i saw her i was impressed
with the modesty wishes
i wanted to go and tell her but as a
preacher you can't just do these things
could be misunderstanding but i said
lord bless that woman
you can tell she respected herself
and she was not advertising for a man
are you following me she was just
dressed modestly covered and i i looked
at her i admired i said god bless that
woman
modesty means very little in the church
today are you with me because our
standards are not biblical or ellen
white they are the world
finish verse 9 of 1st timothy 2 again
what does that say
in like manner also that women adorn
themselves in modest power with
shamefacedness and in other words you
ought to be ashamed if you walk out of
the house looking like that
come on not with
or gold or pearls or costly array now
there's controversy as to what brought
it here means that i have no position on
it but what we do know there are some
hairstyles the bible condemns are you
with me
now some people were chatting all right
whether or not you understand what
broadened hair means it does tell us
there are some hairstyles that god does
not approve of
they do not reflect christian modesty
now you can decide if yours falls under
that or not i'm not here to do that but
i'll tell you that verse condemns
certain hair styles
but there's a holy spirit that convicts
you if you're genuine with god
go to first peter chapter three
we read from verse one
first peter three reading from verse one
have you found that
no some people are still looking
all right we'll wait patience is a
virtue we'll wait
you have five seconds
you have it now
read with me
likewise you wise be in subjection to
your own husbands if any obey not the
word they also may without the word be
won by the conversation of the wife
while they behold your chaste
conversation coupled with fear let me
explain that what peter is telling women
who married to unconverted men
don't like the man
let him see your holy life and that you
still respect him as your husband let
him see that
and that will win him
don't insist he comes to church he's an
adult don't badger him until he seeks
mental help leave the man alone
just be faithful to god
respect him as your husband and that
will do the work all right now
they also made without the word be won
by the consciousness of the while while
they behold your chaste conversation
covered with fear read verse 3 who's
adorning let it not be that outward the
dawning of
letting the hair again or oh
or of putting out of a power meaning
very expensive clothes first 4 but let
it be the hidden man of the heart in
that which is not corruptable so we have
corruptable in verse 4 then what is
corruptable what is in verse 3.
read verse three again
who's adorning let it not be that
outward the dawning of
uh or
wearing of gold or putting off apparel
expensive clothes gold all the weaves
whatever people do
that is corruptable meaning it passes
away verse 4 says but let it be the
hidden man of the heart in that which is
not corruptable even the ornament of a
meek and quiet spirit which in the sight
of god is of great price watson number
three is of no value to god
what's the number four is of great value
to god
and your child of god your first
interest is what is important to god now
read verse five interesting verse for
after this manner
time the holy women also who trusted in
god adorned themselves stop
that's how the holy women of the old
conducted themselves
modestly
so the bible says
now let me finish on jury with this go
to matthew not matthew revelation 12.
i know the subject is not popular i know
that
you're as quiet as a graveyard okay
revelation 12.
do you have revelation 12.
let's read the first one
read with me
and they appeared a great wonder in
heaven a woman clawed of the sun and the
moon under her feet and upon her head a
crown of 12 stars stopped describe how
this woman is adorned how is she
described
clothes of the sun what does the sun
give
light
what were adam and eve surrounded by
before they sinned light keep reading
the moon under her feet what does the
moon give light and upon a head a crown
of 12 stars what do the stars give light
when were they made genesis 1 sun moon
and stars one of their reasons was let
them be for signs for seasons for days
and years and let them be for light in
the firmament of the earth to give light
upon the earth she is adorned in the
light
go to revelation 17.
let's look at another woman
you have revelation 17.
let's reverse fort what does that say
the woman
was arrayed in purple and scarlet color
and decked with gold precious stone and
pearl what do you understand by date
there's a word the rap world gave us
bling are you following me
watch out now from the rap world gave us
bling
i mean the woman in revelation 17 she is
bling-bling it used to be bling-bling
then they shorten it to bling that's
what describes her she was dead
i
couldn't walk straight so heavy with
jewelry
listen to me carefully
the one in twelve is adorned in the
light of christ
the one in seventeen
with all the precious stones and jewelry
the one in twelve represents god's
through church
the one in 17 the corrupt church
you choose which one you'd like to look
like when you dress
i'm not telling you you choose
now let's get off this unpleasant
subject what's the next question
i'm not sure if this one is pleasant
okay okay
what does the bible say about divorce
and remarriage
are adult
adult
well adultery and death
the of the spouse okay the only ground
for remarrying someone else
can you marry someone
who
someone
if someone who has been divorced
yeah okay
let me pray
father in heaven
there's usually a simple answer what
sounds like a complex question tell me
what to tell your people
in jesus name i pray amen
the bible has one clear reason for
divorce
one clear reason
adultery
the church may give you several more
are you with me
the bible has one clear
reason for the divorce that's adultery
you cannot divorce a woman because she
can't cook because you know whatever
adultery that's why when you consider
marriage think twice
but once you're in it you're stuck are
you with me
because that's not a good word you're in
for life
so think twice you can't jump in and
jump out
because she broke a fingernail you can't
do that now
adultery is a reason for divorce now
the bible element makes it very clear
the innocent party can remarry
the guilty party must remain single for
life
of course it doesn't happen because we
do what we want the innocent party can
remarry but god prefers reconciliation
malachi 2 verse 6 the lord of israel
saith that he hateth putting away
calvary shows that god prefers
reconciliation to divorce
are you with me
but
adultery is the clear
biblical reason for divorce
the innocent party can remarry
the guilty party must remain single
so yes you can marry a divorced person
if you determine that the person has
been divorced and the person is innocent
because someone decides to divorce you
there's very little you can do are you
following me it doesn't mean that you're
a monster because you got divorced it
may not been your fault at all
so an innocent person can remarry or can
be married by someone but the clear
biblical reason for divorce is
adultery but the church allows others
presumably based on the bible
all right
but remember when the flood came they
were marrying and giving in marriage
are you following me don't make the
desire for marriage a god
there's some women let me pick on the
women that's all they think about
and they run into trouble they marry the
first man with the pulse are you
following me and they run into trouble
go on
in exodus 28 god gives us instructions
about how we should keep the sabbath day
holy but a lot of seven-day adventists
don't believe that it applies to
strangers or individuals
that are within their gates
they allow them to watch tv stay in
their homes when they go to church and
do whatever they want to do
will the individuals be that allow them
to do this on the sabbath be charged by
god
will it be considered a sin on their
part even though they're not the ones
doing it
let's recite the fourth commandment
remember the sabbath day to keep it holy
six days shalt thou labor and do all thy
work but the seventh day is the sabbath
of the law thy god in it thou shalt not
do any work pause pause that includes
doctors and nurses
[Music]
but let me add something before you call
the police let me add something
ella white writes a medical missionary
page 216 paragraph two it may be
necessary
for doctor or nurse to go in in that
case go because it's proper to ease
suffering on the sabbath but only do
what is required to relieve suffering
and whatever money you paid give it to
the church
so don't go on sabbath saying i'm a
nurse but knowing you want time and a
half
every act is judged by the motive
thou shalt not do any work thou not thy
son thy daughter the man's servant not
my maidservant nor thy cattle nor thy
stranger that is within thy gates
if it's your home
you are responsible
what happens in that home
you cannot say he's my cousin
because god made adam to put him out are
you following me you can't say he's my
cousin let him do what he wants no no no
no
as long as he's in your home he is to
follow the rules now you cannot convert
him but you can let him know in this
house there's no tv on sabbath there's
no smoking
there's no dominoes for you west indians
there's nothing
there's no such thing on the sabbath day
if you don't like it where you can spend
that day elsewhere and then come back at
sunset
are you with me
we must put god first
the honor of god above the comfort of
man
if it's your home you must be
responsible atmosphere in that home
on sabah or any other day of the week
for that matter
so yes god holds you responsible
for allowing in your house what should
not happen on the sabbath day
strictness is not harshness
god said don't touch the ark
other
trying to help
he touched the ark
and we know what happened to him
but god has said
don't
touch it
and god does not joke
next question
that was actually the last question god
is good god is good
i've been going all day
and uh it's good to rest even
there's a hand
okay two hands
all right so let's um use the mic so
that we can
ensure that
don't let these hands turn into a forest
all right danny puts me on the spot okay
yes
all right oh boy
okay go ahead about the doctors and the
nurses yes working on the sound
you know in regards to
healing
on this sabbath so say they weren't
getting paid on this sabbath would that
change things
you don't work on the sabbath okay
jesus said it's lawful to do good
he did not say it's lawful to work you
see if you excuse sabbath work which
gains pay then you must excuse the
firemen and you must excuse because they
have good arguments you must excuse the
policeman you may have to excuse the fbi
agent they quite if you have in this fbi
agent the ten churches in washington dc
we cannot make an exception for any
commandment okay once you do that you
open the floodgates to make exceptions
for all the other nine
in it thou shalt not do any work
and trust god to take care of you
there's a reason why god did not send
manna on sabbath
my enemy is that which keeps your life
you understand because they complained
they were hungry they're about to die he
said man about not on sabbath which
means god does not provide a living on
the sabbath
as i said sometimes no to whom
if you make a living on the sabbath it
didn't come from god
it did not come from god
the devil can give you things don't
misunderstand me but it did not come
from god yes can you repeat the
text from medical missionary
page 216 paragraph two page two sixteen
paragraph two
the chapter is the the sanitarium family
something like that
all right where's the other hand
pastor i know the answer to the question
i'm gonna ask you all right but to my
friend here
i want him to hear it from you okay
um
if you were baptized in another faith
yes
and you come to the seventh-day
adventist
shouldn't you re-baptize
the strong
council is to get re-baptized now in
acts chapter 19
paul met 12 disciples who had been
baptized by john acts 19 1-7
john said unto paul said unto which
baptism were you baptized you said
john's baptism
john they said have you received the
holy ghost since you were baptized you
said we never heard about the holy ghost
what
he taught them then they were
re-baptized
when you realize you're coming to system
of truth you were not familiar with
now of course it's up to the spirit to
convict you your decisions should be let
me be re-baptized and start all over in
this new system of truth
the recommendation it's not a command
it's a recommendation be re-baptized
i was preaching somewhere
way over the seas
and
i made a call for baptism rebaptism 50
people came
my call was look you've been with god 40
years but you haven't grown
it's just a routine it's just you're
going through the motions you need to
start again
and 50 people came
and i took them aside to a room to speak
to them and a retired minister joined me
and he told us a very interesting story
in the middle of his ministry
he decided to be re-baptized because he
realized he hadn't grown he was passing
the church they were baptism the tithe
was fine but he himself was not really
growing so he went to the conference and
said mr president i want to be
re-baptized the person said what did you
do oh i didn't do anything
but i realized my spiritual life has
been just nothing
and i just can't go through the motions
i want to be re-baptized the president
said okay we'll re-baptize you at night
the pastor said no
baptize me in front of my church because
there are the members who need to make
the same step let them see
and he was re-baptized i was preaching
in another city
the associate pastor got re-baptized
i was in another city preaching the
pastor's wife and his son got
re-baptized because something about the
word revive them evangelism page 375
elohimite writes when a soul is truly
reconverted let that soul be re-baptized
let him renew his covenant with god and
god will renew his covenant with him
reconversion must take place in the
churches
the strong council of the church is get
re-baptized
new beginning
all right who has the next hand yes my
brother yes good evening pastor
thank you for everything have a question
concerning our communion services it
looks like
things have been changing all right
how i was
brought up in or when i came into the
church i was taught that
when having communion service the
morning part of the service you know you
the pastor preaches a sermon concerning
the last supper
and then you wash feet
then you come and and come on partake of
right service
and then when you leave you know the the
left
singing him right right
um
what i've seen or what was tried to
that was um try to be implemented was
everything done be done in the morning
part of washington field and then preach
the sermon and then have benediction
and leave
so i stated you know about how i
understood it and mark and then you
leave yes when do you partake of the
emblems yes sir and then you sing and
then we leave uh
after the hymn we sung and we leave
singing
so i don't know what's what's your take
on i i didn't catch the difference
though i didn't catch the difference oh
sorry
you said the new thing you're seeing is
what oh well the new thing
they switch it around so instead of
having everything in the evening sorry
the the washing of the field after after
the sermon they they want to do
everything
the washing of defeat the communion
service first and then they'll purchase
a sermon
and then
have a
do a benediction to close the service
so is that
also
accepted
oh no feet washing no no he's saying
that the preaching came after the
communion
there's no biblical mandate for when the
preaching should come
it's a matter of style and preference
the preaching can come anywhere
yeah it can come anywhere
it doesn't have to be before the emblems
or after it depends on what the people
prefer yes it's a choice it's a choice i
mean you look at every church they're a
list of all preliminaries they vary from
church to church i've been to churches
to preach i had to wait 90 minutes
before i spoke there were 90 minutes of
preliminaries and maybe the church
baptized five people in 40 years but
they have 90 minutes of preliminaries
are you following me and i can
understand it but anyway it's a personal
choice it's a personal choice yes yes
for instance you have offering am i
first right then you have what a morning
prayer whatever you can switch that
around now it accepts people
you have morning prayer before the
offering some people get very upset if
you change the order of service
the order of service is not a biblical
mandate it depends on the individual
church
oh you welcome god bless you
yes sister this question concerns those
who work in the medical field yes the
nurses
doctors
what happened to our
institution
our hospitals and so forth
they pay
because they have to work on sabbath
yeah they pay they pay
in many things we do sister we're just
like the world in many now this is my
church i'll die for it you can't get me
out of this church except in a coffin
but i also know there are many things we
do that are simply influenced by the
world whether it's our hospitals our
schools our publishing houses you know i
just sometimes you shake your head and
you realize the israelites were no
different
they were god's people but crazy
and we are very much that way but don't
give up this is god's church it is the
object still of his supreme regard i was
an advertised bookstore once and i have
books by td jake and this but i said
what's the problem here
and you know this
come on
are we here to make a difference or not
you go to hospitals you see a vending
machine with coke and sprite and you
know we have a health message
but we're still god's people and god has
to spank us sometimes to get us straight
so don't be discouraged sister
we're still god's people pray do what
you can god will fix this church
when he does it will be painful
uh i need a pastor's
yes permission
pastor i have a i have a question
so um
last week you on your topic um obedience
has side effects
yes and again this morning
you spoke about the sabbath
and so um i have friends and from time
to time we have you know discussions
about the seventh day the seventh day
yes yes and so i have i have one friend
and he says well
the bible doesn't the bible didn't say
monday tuesday when sunday monday
tuesday wednesday thursday friday
matter of fact it says 1st 2nd 3rd 4th
4th 6th the only day that it named
was the sabbath
so
his argument is
um
wednesday could be the first day so my
seventh day could be the following
wednesday mm-hmm what why can i
you know worship on that day make that
day holy all right so my question is
since um
you know god named first second third
fourth fifth man made today sunday
morning tuesday wednesday thursday how
do you all right okay
after this have a bible study method
called here a little
very little
line upon line preset upon prison all
right
let me ask you this
on what day
was jesus did jesus rise from the tomb
the bible says on the first day all
consistently the first day matthew mark
luke's first day now
let's forget adventists for a while
on which day do christians celebrate
easter
all christians celebrate easter on
sunday because they know from the bible
what happened on that day that's when
you see easter celebrates the
resurrection of jesus so your friend who
has a problem let him look at easter now
on what day was christ crucified they
also celebrated it's called what good
friday
and there's no argument the whole
christian world celebrates you look at
your calendars and you'll see easter is
on a sunday
now you tell me what's the day between
friday and saturday
[Music]
simple if you're honest
and you're thinking the bible does not
leave us with doubt on critical issues
we have to think
that the catholics celebrate east on
sunday the same people who change the
law huh they celebrate easter on sunday
they celebrate good friday on friday ash
wednesday on wednesday and holy thursday
on thursday are you following me and
there's also an entire nation that has
been on the earth for thousands of years
who know when the seventh day is the
jewish nation
all right
may god lead your friend to light pastor
you're my boss you tell me who dams two
more two more two more okay
all right i have to say two more all
right and the case is closed yes
two questions
[Laughter]
okay professor
yes number one
it's competitive sports yes
acknowledged by god
is what
is it acknowledged by god acknowledged
yes okay okay
and the other question is
improperly doing communion partaking of
communion right
food washing is necessary
because of the situation we're in now
should we feel that as a people of god
should we do one fear
for washing as a people of god
okay all right so those two questions
okay all right
let me get to them one competitive
sports they are not of god
they're contrary to the spirit of christ
christ's spirit is i lose so you can win
that's calvary
i lose
for your sakes he became poor that ye
through his poverty might become rich
competitive sport says i will do
everything i can to stop you from
scoring one goal
i will slam you to the boards in ice
hockey i will break your legs in
football i will look undercut you in
basketball i will whatever
competitive sports are not of god
i'm upsetting those of you who worship
arsenal manchester united competitive
sports are not of god is the houston
astros or whatever they are not of god
are you with me recreation is of god
difference i remember many years ago i
was in the house of a friend of mine and
he had a table tennis in the basement so
he and i were just hitting the ball
he said let's play a game i said why
come on let's play why let's hit the
ball
come on let's play a game so we played i
beat him 21-5
and that was the end of his desire to
play a game he wanted someone to win or
lose this is not the spirit of god
you see it on pick up games on the
playgrounds someone fouled no i didn't
follow you fouled he looked like a foul
you fouled it
no not me they put their hands up lying
lying
competitive sports are not of god what
was the other one
offered washing
we shouldn't fear doing what god has
told us to do
we shouldn't fear it let me tell you
something
god said don't cook on sabbath
is this mic working
the bible tells us do not cook on
sabbath
cook that's why there's a preparation
day
an entire day
now the bible say that god is the same
yesterday today and forever
if he kept the food fresh in the days of
the manner can he cook to keep the food
fresh today yes
whether you have a fridge or not
because god rewards obedience are you
listening to me do not cook on sabbath
now everyone says you can warm the food
but don't get cute and make it a cookish
warming are you following me just warm
it
[Music]
we're always trying to get around god
well i'm not cooking i'm warming up the
cooking no not don't cook but you can
warm it
but when god says do it do it do not be
afraid
all right
pastor is that it
one more one more who's that person
oh my good brother yes
yes if you have an art with your brother
yes and you go to him and you apologize
and he says i i don't accept your
apology
what what is the state of that good
question
there are a lot of problems in churches
because members will not apologize to
each other they prefer to go gossip
instead of following matthew 18 15-17
moreover if thy brother shall trespass
against thee go and tell him his fault
between thee and him
alone
if we would do that step one
we would cut out a lot of interpersonal
problems in the church but we call our
friends we text this person we skype
that person we you know
and we discuss it
and damage the person
the biblical method is always best
if someone is offended you go to that
person
it provides release for you and a chance
for the person to be free from the guilt
if the person does not accept you then
there's nothing you can do but you can
try again
because jesus said 70 times seven he was
willing to forgive
you can try again but if it's clear the
person is not you have done your part
and god accepts that because the person
is as much required by god to accept
your confession or your apology as you
are to give it
both things must work
but some people they wrap their arms and
no i'm not accepting your apology that
is not of god
the greatest offense is sin and god
accepts our apologies when we confess
we're to be like him all right that's
the end of it my brothers and sisters
may god bless you
listen to me carefully
study the word of god
please
christ object lessons page 100 paragraph
one
the scriptures are the chief agency in
the transformation of character
jesus prayed sanctified him through thy
truth
thy word is truth elohim shows if
studied and obeyed
the word of god works in the heart
subduing
every unholy attribute
when christ comes back he raises the
dead
with the word
until then he will sustain us by the
word and take time to read the writings
of ellen white please
god bless you
wherever you are if i come across your
mind please say lord
put your words in that man's mouth god
bless you
[Music]